Anantha be is apparently back from I
think she took a break from doing her
show you can tell because of the aroma
of [ __ ] that fills the studio at CBS in
June she is I believe the worst offender
of completely taking clips out of
context she did it this week well first
let's watch her set it up after briefly
banning Kellyanne Conway for being a
flaxen-haired Fountain of Life
CNN let her back through the gate
straight into Jake Tapper's cage and
they haven't fed him this week what was
he talking about was so that was so just
it was just such an own such an epic
fail for Kellyanne Conway here's the
montage she showed her audience saying
that we don't cover terrorism that's
just false sprayings of falsehood coming
from the White House how about the
president's statements that are false
falsehoods fall fall Oh first glance yes
it would look like Jake got the better
of those exchanges now it's easy to look
as though you mop the floor with someone
when you don't show any of their
responses it's like arguing with a
kung-fu doll here's the thing with this
taking someone out of context we get
this lot like oh you edited a clip you
edited a video we get that a lot when we
do hidden-camera video all videos are
edited all clips are edited okay by
definition if you have 19 hours of raw
footage and you have a 10 minute video
that's selectively editing so I don't
want to claim that here here's what's
important anything out of context means
you're making something look to be an
event that it wasn't maybe even making
it look to be the opposite so Samantha
bee does it and she's not really making
comedic points she's using it to make
political points look at her sources on
the show it's almost always Phil on Vox
daily costs Huffington Post so you know
where she's coming from no context was
provided here is how Kellyanne Conway
answered those even seated questions you
just saw accusations are false but you
tell me if it looks like an owned but
the president is saying there
Jake is that there are other attacks
that don't get as much coverage
obviously the very sad incidents that
you related were frankly CNN did amazing
coverage well I did this past week and I
regretted it tremendously because I use
the wrong word to describe something
several times and I'm sorry because I've
spoken literally millions of words on TV
I'm sure I've handed the information I
think you referred to it as well that we
have had an increase from 2014 to 2015 I
wrote in rapes and murders and assaults
I'm probably looking at the same data
you are sounds pretty reasonable yeah
you know what maybe even Jake maybe Jake
Tapper even got the better for in that
interview maybe it wasn't Kellyanne
Conway's strongest interview I'd advise
going to watch at the full 25-minute
interview I think we have it up at
louder with Crider calm but it certainly
wasn't in owned and owning now and and
one could say that's an isolated
incident but in a very sane show I would
argue taking out of context minutes
later minutes later Samantha be
presented the debate between senator Ted
Cruz and senator Bernie Sanders as going
down like this I disagree with Ted who
wants to give incredible tax breaks to
millionaires and do you know when my dad
went to Texas in 1957 when he was 18 he
couldn't speak English incredible tax
breaks to the top one culture and
Bernie's solution you know I'm reminded
of an old Saturday Night Live skit with
Christopher Walken where they're playing
in a band and he keeps ringing the
cowbell now that being said Ted Cruz
didn't make it that joke sound
incredibly serious baby poor delivery
agreement now why did the chicken mat
now why did the chicken cross the road
vote for me I'll give her that but
you're saying they tried to make it seem
as though Bernie was substantive that's
probably the one time Bernie ever
reference numbers right it was about one
person yes that really looks back as
much it's just it's just a figure and
they try to make it sound like Ted Cruz
was nonsensical and just going off on
tangents as though it wasn't clearly
Bernie Sanders looking like someone
trying to escape the old folks home or
just wandered in playing they didn't
make it out of light no still there's no
way right right that's a pretty definite
no this is important to note because
even even impartial observers said you
know what this is not a good showing for
Bernie which shows you that Samantha B
can't even be honest in her
we genuinely try to be honest here at
least object and I know we have bought
we all have an Erin biases so I'll
forgive that
but the proactive editing if you watch
or show all the time and then afterwards
she does something so dishonest trying
to give herself a pat in the back watch
I can honestly say I would give my left
tit to have either one of you wonderful
mansplaining pricks in the White House
right now right now and everyone cheers
this is why Donald Trump should not
apologize this is why conservatives out
there should not apologize this is why
guilted browbeating dear white people
should not apologize because what the
left does right they go well now because
of Trump Ted Cruz just like they'll say
well you know what compared to Trump
John McCain is okay or Mitt Romney is
okay or Mitch McConnell is okay or Ted
Cruz is okay they say it now when
they're no longer a threat but when
those same people if you go back in time
when every single one of them was
politically relevant they got the exact
same attacks and treatment as Donald
Trump you were racist xenophobic
transphobic homophobic they only try and
concede some ground when you're no
longer running for office so Samantha be
now trying to act as though she would
take the moral high road well not all
Republicans are the same Donald Trump is
really bad I could have been okay with
Ted Cruz well here's what she actually
had to say about Ted Cruz Oh as Ted Cruz
and why is he so hated and how come he
always looks like he's covered in a
glistening layer of fine even though we
know that can't possibly be true good
heads believe in dominionism I hope not
it certainly contradicts that book he
memorized in high school while no one
was having sex with them even God cannot
stand to have a direct conversation
that cruise by the way after that she
volunteered her time for an
anti-bullying campaign would it be so
hard to swallow if you know they didn't
just turn around and I can't believe
that our president a state god literally
hates Ted Cruz is that a naughty word
innocent we you know this is what we
streamed it you were rather you're both
there yes I was mostly there and well um
we live streamed the entire debate the
entire debate and we encourage people to
watch the entire we get it with every
single presidential debate and primary
debate they we looked at all but then
just cut the highlight reel for you and
you know what that means is we can't
hide in the kind of dishonesty to the
left does not what if we watch an entire
debate for example if we watch the whole
debate and if Bernie Sanders really
mopped the floor with Ted Cruz we would
have to go well this doesn't look this
is not a good day for Ted you know why
because we would look silly if we simply
lied to you are you going to believe me
or your lying eyes and ears so we
provide as much context as possible and
it keeps just somewhat accountable and
this shows you again the left is a
system on ideas and certainly a
political platform today that relies on
giving you less information that relies
on keeping you in the dark
it relies on not informing you as to how
economics work I'm not informing you it
to how taxes are procured it relies I'm
not informing you as to how expensive
health care is it relies on less
information whereas the big camp I don't
even say conservatism but conservatism
libertarianism whatever Dave Rubin is
ISM actually requires more information
and is accountable
I don't know maybe it's just me if you
liked this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clips from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside